- I think in general
the government is not
good at what it does.
It's either incompetent or
ineffective or inefficient,
or it's kind of villainous.
One of the reasons you had asked
how did I become a libertarian,
and part of it is after
I graduated college,
and before I got into the
lucrative teen mag business,
(laughing)
I wrote for a bunch of
newspapers in New Jersey,
I was a reporter
and I would always have to go
to planning board meetings.
And like, if you wanna turn
people into libertarians,
like just busload school kids,
bus school kids to planning
board meetings where people,
just the people in charge
just rail against anybody
who had the temerity to
like improve their land
or their house without
getting the right permits,
and half the cases I saw, people
didn't even know like, oh,
I needed to go to the city
council to put up a fence
or like to make my house better.
It's like, screw you.
(upbeat ambient music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the editor-at-large
of "Reason Magazine"
and host of "The
Reason Interview",
Nick Gillespie finally,
welcome to "The Rubin Report".
- Thanks for having me Dave,
I really appreciate it.
- So this is very
bizarre for me to admit,
but we played a clip of
"Real Time with Bill Maher"
last week with Heidi Heitkamp
accusing Gina Carano
of basically being a Nazi
and a white supremacist,
and you were sitting
next to Heidi Heitkamp
when she said this.
And I played the clip
and then I said, oh,
there's my buddy, Nick Gillespie
from Reason Magazine for,
I think I said former
guest of The Rubin Report,
and then we realized after that
we've never done this somehow
and I feel bad.
- Yeah.
- I usually don't apologize
at the beginning of a show,
but I feel bad that you've
never been here before.
- I, in many contexts,
I perform after,
I apologize after
performance failures.
(chuckles)
So I, please don't apologize,
I'm happy to be here.
I know I've gotten to interview
you twice, once for Reason
and once at Students for
Liberty at LibertyCon.
So it's nice to be on the
other side of the mic.
- All right.
One way or another, here we are.
- Yeah.
- It's overdue,
but we got a lot to get to.
But let's.
- Yeah.
- Start with that clip,
because I wanna spend a lot of
time obviously talking about
libertarianism and if
there's any differences
between libertarianism
and classical liberalism
and what should libertarians
do now and all that good stuff.
But since the clip was
what got us here today,
let's start with that.
So I'm gonna throw to
it to her right now.
- Who was the woman
in "The Mandalorian",
what did she do,
she liked something?
- [Heidi] She was a Nazi.
- Oh, that's different.
- Yeah.
- Right,
I'm thinking of somebody else,
(laughing)
well, she's not a Nazi, she.
- She's a white.
- Not a Nazi,
look at that.
- She's involved
with white supremacy.
- You're calling her a Nazi.
- She's called
other people Nazi's.
- Right.
- She's the Nazi.
- Okay, everyone's a Nazi now.
- Yeah.
(crowd laughing)
- She does hang with
white supremacists.
- It's like a Mel Brooks
movie.
- She does?
- Yeah.
- [Bill] Hangs with white?
- I suppose I'm now
subject to defamation.
- I don't know.
I mean it depends on
what your definition
of white supremacist is.
That also.
- You're.
- The goalpost
there changed a lot.
- Your.
- It used be a guy
in clan hood, who.
now it's a.
- I think we have to
be really careful, there's two
things the Republicans think
they're gonna get Biden on,
Cancel Culture
and this whole Dr. Seuss
stuff that's going on,
where they're reading
green eggs and ham,
proving that some of these
senators can actually read
and.
(audience laughing)
(audience applause)
And immigration.
And so we can't ignore the
fact that we got Donald Trump
was in part because of
political correctness.
- Okay.
So there's obviously a bunch
to unpack there
(chuckles)
and it sort of
seems to me by the,
by your sort of quick reaction,
it's like, when you're
doing this on live TV,
sometimes people say
something so over the top,
you kinda don't
know how to react.
Can you just lay out
what was going through
your mind during that?
- You know, there were
a lot of moments where
I was kinda looking to my left
and I was like, this is
a former U.S. Senator
and I didn't understand
where she was coming from.
That was certainly part of it.
And you know, the whole,
I grew up in the 70s and
80s and "Hogan's Heroes"
and Mel Brooks movies
were still everywhere.
- Yeah.
- And they always were making
fun of Nazis, I never thought
I would live in America,
my father in World War
II fought the Nazis.
I mean, he was in Europe
fighting as an infantry man.
I never thought that people
would be seriously lobbing
charges of Nazi-ism,
just as a way of shutting down
all sorts of conversation.
What I liked in that clip,
or what I liked in
the reaction there
is that Bill Maher
has really stepped up
as a massive defender
of free speech.
- Yeah.
- And I disagree with him
about a lot of things,
I'm sure you do too,
but fundamentally,
what you want in a,
what you want in anybody
in media certainly,
and anybody in any kind
of intellectual endeavor
to be pushing for free speech.
And I was glad to
see him push back
in a way that was
refreshing, because,
and you could see how
I think Heidi in a way,
is a proxy for a lot of
people broadly on the left.
I mean she's actually
a centrist Democrat,
but where they say,
well somebody's a Nazi,
and then it's like no
they're not a Nazi,
they accuse somebody else
of being like the Nazis,
then it's like, well they
hang out with the alt-right.
Then they do this,
then they do that
and there's almost like a
series of decision trees
where it's like okay, not
a Nazi, but then this,
not this but then that.
And so it's a nice
encapsulation,
I think of a thought process
that is unfortunately rampant
in public discourse right now.
- Yeah, and you could sort of
see the way she was laughing
and smiling over
what she was saying,
that she didn't even believe it,
or even know what she
was saying in a way.
- I think that second part is
probably more to the point.
And I have to say I
enjoy talking with her,
in some ways, if there
were more Democrats
like her still in the Senate.
- Yeah.
- I don't think
we would be seeing
the same level of
spending, et cetera.
Having said that, I mean
it's a little bit promiscuous
to call somebody a Nazi and
then not even know who they are
or what they were talking about,
and then just kind of trail
off into, well, you know,
maybe they're not Nazis
but they hang out with people
who hang out with people
who hang out with Nazis,
who aren't really Nazis.
Enough already.
(chuckles)
- Yeah, it is enough already.
Real quick on Bill Maher,
'cause I think you said
something interesting there,
he is, what I would say,
is maybe one of the last
10 public intellectuals
or comedians,
whatever you wanna call them.
- Yeah.
- That is offering what
I would say is a liberal,
a true liberal defense
of free speech.
- Yeah.
- That obviously
you guys like us
are completely aligned with.
- Right.
- But my frustration
with him at this point is
I want him to just say at
this point he's a libertarian,
basically.
Just say it Bill,
you wanna smoke pot.
You wanna live your life, you're
a bachelor at 60, whatever,
with millions of dollars and
go to the Playboy Mansion
or whatever is left with it.
- Yeah, I don't know,
is there even a Playboy
Mansion left that anymore?
Playboy Mansion and COVID is.
- Somebody bought it
and I don't know
what's going on there.
But, to me it's like
Bill is this odd thing
where he'll bring on Adam Schiff
and say, all my
friends are leaving
and California is not.
- Right.
- Business friendly,
but then he'll still
support Democrats,
and I'm struggling with
that, help me Nick.
- So back in the 90s,
the first time I
interviewed Bill Maher for,
"Reason" has been around
since 1968, I joined in 1993,
I interviewed Bill at
some point in the mid 90s
and he was calling himself
a libertarian then.
He was not particularly
ideological,
he's not a card-carrying
member, I don't think
of anything other than maybe
PIDA to be quite honest,
but what he meant by that
was that he was in
favor of free speech,
he was against censorship,
which is a huge thing.
I mean, people forget in the 90s
Janet Reno and Bill Clinton,
along with all major
Republicans like Bob Dole.
- Yeah.
- If anybody remembers him,
they were all talking
about censoring cable TV
for having too much
sex and violence.
And you know we're talking
about like basic cable,
any he pushed back on that,
he was very big in
favor of free speech,
in favor of kind
of open sexuality,
which was kind of
forward back then, avant.
And then he, I think
with Bush and then Obama
and then certainly Trump,
he started rolling
more with Democrats
in terms of economic policy.
And so, I actually think,
and I'm happy to
talk about this more,
I think there is a kind of,
I consider myself a
libertarian without adjectives.
I believe in what reason calls
free minds and free markets.
I want choice in everything.
- Huh-uh.
- You know,
from abortion to schools, to
food, to marriage, whatever.
And but there are
people on the right
who are more conservative
and are libertarian in spirit
or in many policies,
people on the left.
And I think Bill Maher
is pretty good there
on the left side of things.
And his really important
function now is
he is one of the few
people in a kind of major,
what's now legacy media.
It's funny to think
that HBO is actually
kind of old school.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- But he was sticking up
for freedom of speech and
freedom of expression.
And, at point in that
show, he was saying like,
can we hold two thoughts
at the same time that
for instance, that
we were talking
about Asian violence
against Asians in America,
and he was like, yeah,
there could be some of
that coming out of COVID
but it's also that the
Atlanta shooting was not that.
- Hmm.
- And I like
to hear that kind of stuff,
from whether it's from
the right or the left,
like people who are just saying,
let's have a conversation that
is not simply talking points
or, slurs like Heidi
Heitkamp was tossing around.
- So it sounds to me like
you'd kind of love him
to say he was a
libertarian in a way,
'cause it would be great
for libertarianism,
but on another hand.
- Huh.
- He serves this sort of
function.
- Yeah.
- As a remaining liberal
let's say.
- I think so, yeah.
And, again like right left
libertarians, like some are,
sometimes you hear
conservatorium and
left libertarians
and whatever, I'm less
interested in that
and the slogans or the labels
and I'm more interested in like
when you see people actually
having conversations
and one of the great virtues
of his show, I think real time
and before that politically
incorrect when it was on ABC
- Hmm.
- And before that
on Comedy Central,
was that it was a
staging ground for
people who disagree
with each other,
getting to air there,
to have a conversation
or even an argument for more
than 30 seconds at a time.
One of the things that
I think you've done
in a host of other people
is really take advantage
of the space and time
that YouTube and
other platforms,
the Blaze actually is also
a fascinating network to me.
- Yeah.
- Because it's,
the one thing you can't say
about the Blaze is that,
oh, they're only talking
in 15 second sound bites,
like CNN and MSNBC or Fox even,
like these are long shows
that are taking advantage of
the time and space we have.
So more power to
build more for them.
- Yeah, all right.
So let's move off Bill
Maher for a moment.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna keep working,
I'm gonna keep nudging him
on my show.
- yeah.
- That's my plan is just
to keep nudging him,
'cause it's like the Democrats,
when they come to cancel him,
I said this to him once at
an after party at Realtime,
I said, you know, when they
come to get you one day,
it's gonna be the
left, not the right.
- Yeah. I think he
knows that because I,
and I think it was
during the show,
like a portion of that era,
because of COVID there were
fewer guests and no after party
or anything like that,
but he was saying that
like when he goes places
like people are often
afraid to speak up
even in private gatherings
because if you don't
know everybody,
I mean, it's kind of like
everybody's in the mafia
and they're always figuring
there's a couple of
federal agents who are
recording everything,
so you don't say anything
if you don't know everybody,
what a fucked up
world to be living in,
like where we have, some
time since the early 60s,
we kicked free of all
the dumbest restraints
on free speech,
government censorship,
you could publish,
you couldn't legally publish
"Lady Chatterley's Lover"
James Joyce's, "Ulysses",
Henry Miller's, "Tropic of
Cancer", Alan Ginsberg's, "Howl"
before about 1960
without worrying about
being dragged into court,
we got rid of all of that
and then we created the internet
which is like an
infinite hard drive
where you can just load
up everything you want.
And we're arguing now about like
policing each other speech in
such picky and horrible ways.
It's tragic really.
- There's basically
a protection racket
and nobody knows who's in it.
So everyone is sort of.
- Yeah.
- Hostage at some level.
All right, so let's just
back up for a second,
because I do sort
of consider you
because of what
you do with Reason,
and you've been
doing this for for a
couple of decades now.
- Forever.
- Forever, basically,
although I am noticing you're
wearing a suede jacket today
instead of your trademark
leather jacket.
- Well, you know.
Yeah, I think of suede leather
as the same thing really.
(chuckles)
This is a jacket
that my girlfriend got me for
Christmas and I like it a lot,
and I've been out
in LA for a while,
I'm usually in New York or DC,
and it's kind of
a cowboy jacket.
So what the hell.
- People know that
is Nick Gillespie
walking down the street.
but where did this
all start with you?
This idea of
freedom and Liberty?
- Yeah.
- Was this
five-year-old Nick
(chuckles)
wanting to play
fairly with his friends.
- Well.
- And maybe even exchanges.
- I did go to a Catholic school,
so like you learn
pretty quickly that
people wanna impose
limits on everything
and then you kind of like,
you get tired of
those limits somewhat.
But a lot of it I think is
just kind of dispositional.
I think people, some people
are born wanting to be
able just to do what they want
as long as they're not
hurting other people,
which I think is a
kind of basic impulse
that defines libertarianism
or libertarian ideas.
I don't even like to use
it as a noun anymore,
I don't like to say.
- Hmm-mm.
- I am a libertarian
or there is a thing
called libertarianism.
I think it's more directional,
I think it's temperamental,
I think it's,
do you think that people
should be given more choice,
more autonomy, more freedom
in any given situation
as the default?
Sometimes we override that,
but in general, it's like,
yeah, let's have more freedom
and I'm happy that my
life, I was born in 63,
most of my life
in most big ways,
we have been getting
more and more free.
And I think that's great
economically, culturally,
individually, lifestyle
wise and stuff.
But a big part of it was
actually my brother
who's older than me,
I was born in Brooklyn,
but grew up in New Jersey.
And my brother went to
college at Rutgers as I did
and he discovered Reason
Magazine in the bookstore
and started sending
it home to me,
and I was like, oh wow, that's
really interesting stuff.
The way they do analysis
of the outcomes of policies
as opposed to simply
the intentions.
And a lot of times
things that are done
in the name of making people
more free or more
equal or better off,
end up having the
opposite result
and that really spoke to me.
And basically by the
time I got to college,
I was calling
myself libertarian.
And then I went to,
I worked for a while as
a teen magazine editor,
a music editor, a
music magazine editor
and you meet a lot
of people there
who are very into
free expression,
particularly among teen stars.
You've never met
people who want to
have no restraints put
on them whatsoever,
as you know.
- Right.
- As Corey Haim
or Corey Feldman.
- At least at that time,
I'm not sure if those magazines.
- Yes.
- Are so into
free expression these days.
- No, they are certainly not.
- Yeah.
- But in any case,
I went back to grad school for
English and cultural studies,
literary and cultural
studies in the late 80s,
and that was the time
when, what we were calling,
it was political correctness.
- Hmm.
- Kind of
what has become
wokeness, woke activism.
And I realized I
needed an etiology
because I wasn't a
conservative aesthetically
or personally or
temperamentally,
and I certainly
wasn't a progressive,
because these were people
who really started,
this was the beginning of
really clamping down on speech
and of using identity politics
or something like that
to shut down conversation
rather than open things up,
which I thought, that's why I
wanted to, go into academia.
And I took libertarian
thought more seriously
and that's kind of,
and then I got a job
working at Reason, so.
- It's interesting because
you mentioned something about
sort of how we're
wired or temperament.
And I do notice that
one of the reasons
I love going to
libertarian talks
and events and college things
and YAF and all of
those things and YAL
and all those, there's
a lot of Y's in there.
- Yeah.
- But is that the
general disposition of people?
Because the default is I don't
want to control everyone.
- Right.
- The disposition
is quite pleasant.
I mean, there's very rarely,
can you remember once going
to a libertarian event?
I mean, they got the
convention with the naked guy,
but where it's like a
real fire and brimstone,
like angry people.
And I think that that's
an important piece of this
which may be just sort
of how we're wired.
- I think, well, two things,
one is libertarians believe in
what sometimes gets called
"the right of exit",
and so like, if you have
a conference in Las Vegas
or Washington DC or
Antarctica, whatever
and then you start screaming
and yelling at people
that they're gonna go to hell
or that they're not allowed
to do what you want.
Like, people leave that room
and they go out the hallway.
- Right.
- And start talking.
So, it works pretty well.
I think for me one
of the questions is,
I don't think it's simply,
you're either born
this way or that way.
I like Lady Gaga was music,
and I liked the idea when her
concept of "Born That Way",
makes sense for a lot of things,
including I think broadly
speaking sexual orientation,
but I'm in the
business of wanting
to make more libertarians
or make the case
that a libertarian world.
- Hmm.
- Is more, is better, it
leads to better outcomes.
It's more fair, it's more
innovative, it's more fun.
And you are not
constantly spending
90% of your bandwidth
on making sure
that you're not saying something
that is gonna get you canceled
or yelled at or put in prison.
To me,
I'm glad to hear
you talking about
how like libertarian events
are kind of fun to go to
and stuff like that,
I wanna see us grow both
as a cultural force,
more than a political force.
'Cause I agree with people
like Andrew Breitbart
that politics is a lagging
indicator of culture.
And what worries me
is that over the past,
certainly over the
past decade or so,
it feels like we
are going backward.
People are trying to throw it,
it's like people are
throwing a weighted blanket.
- Hmm-mm.
- Over everything
in American culture,
the economy,
the culture itself, et cetera
and that really,
really worries me.
- A weighted blanket is nice
for the first few minutes
but three hours later.
- That's right.
- When you can't get up
and it's only three in the
afternoon, it's a real problem.
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
now, it's like only old,
scared, anxious people
need weighted blankets.
And I'm glad that we
have a free market
that provides millions of
different types of
weighted blankets
with whatever superhero
you want and frost on it
and everything, but like,
I don't wanna live in
a world where that's,
you're spending the
first half of every day
fighting to get out
from under the covers.
- So I wanna bring up a
completely fictitious event
because obviously
this didn't happen,
but let's just say
one of us had a party
a little bit after the election,
and let's just say
there were a bunch
of political people
at this party
and we were sitting around
a fire and let's just say,
maybe there were a couple of
joints being passed around,
and let's just say some of
the people voted for Trump
and some of the people
voted for Biden.
This of course is
completely fictitious,
neither one of us,
good, decent citizens.
- Yeah.
- Law abiding, whatever,
do something like this.
And let's just say some of
the Biden people
were feeling good
and the Trump people were
kind of feeling upset.
And let's just say you,
and again this is
completely fictitious.
- Okay.
- Actually said to everybody,
maybe everyone
needs to calm down
because this is just the
cyclical nature of politics.
I mean.
- Hmm.
- Perhaps
it was just the weed talking,
but do you really feel that way?
(chuckles)
That even now
as you see what I think.
- Yeah.
- And if you take
a different position, it's fine.
- Sure.
- An administration
that's sort of out of control
and now we're gonna
expand the courts
and all of this stuff, do you
still feel calm within that?
And that's a little bit
of the previous question,
just related to
temperament to.
- No, no, I think it's great
and the one thing I
wanna point out is,
of course in California,
smoking weed is legal
which is something that it was,
obviously was gonna happen.
When I started at Reason in 1993
and there was the first
medical marijuana vote,
a ballot initiative
in California in '96
which won overwhelmingly.
You knew legal weed
was gonna come,
but it's kind of
amazing that it came
and,
a majority of people in America
live in states where
recreational weed is legal.
You know, the drug war is ending
and it's kind of phenomenal.
So and that's like one of the,
libertarians don't
have a lot of wins.
- Hmm-mm.
- But this is something,
the first issue
of Reason in 1968
talked about ending the drug war
before Richard Nixon
had even escalated it
in the very early 70s.
So.
- Hmm.
- It's kind of good to step back
every once in a while and say
like, you know what, like,
there's a lot of
terrible stuff going on,
but, in many ways
things are pretty good.
To your larger point,
I think what we've specifically,
we're talking about in
a fictional universe.
- A completely
fictional universe.
- Yeah, absolutely,
absolutely, it takes place
on the other side of earth,
a negative earth or
something, counter earth.
- The food was delicious though
at that fictitious event,
wasn't it?
- I seem to remember
(chuckles)
looking at that
and thinking, wow, in
a fictional universe,
I wish I could eat that
food in my actual place.
But it had more to do with
things about free speech
and where we were going
because I had written
before the election
and this is something I
voted for Joe Jorgensen,
I almost never vote,
actually, I've only voted for
a major party candidate once
in any election at any level,
that was Walter Mondale in 1984.
I don't know what I was doing.
- It did not go well.
- Yeah.
And it's like, I think what
I liked about him was that he
said he was gonna raise
taxes to close the deficit.
And I was like,
okay, that's honest,
it's suicide, but it's honest.
But in any case, I had
written before the election,
here are 11 trillion reasons
to be scared shitless about
Joe Biden becoming president
because he had offered $11
trillion in new spending
in his campaign platform.
And that's really bad because
Donald Trump had actually met,
or under Donald Trump,
the budget had already
massively increased
from when he took office,
Obama things ratcheted
up from 2009,
his first budget
year to him leaving,
Bush, had increased
spending 50%.
We have to stop
spending so much money
especially since we're
not paying for it.
So I'm not a fan of Joe Biden.
I do think that we still live
in a world of free speech.
I dislike very much the way
the social media platforms,
the Facebooks, Twitter, YouTubes
of the world are
clamping down on speech,
I think that's inarguable
and we have to
scream bloody murder
and also build
alternatives to that.
Let's talk about
that in a second.
- Yeah.
- You're specifically,
I think Joe Biden is delivering
on exactly what he promised
and that is a dark winter.
- Yeah.
- For America
on every level.
- Yeah.
- And to this point, like
I was just reading today,
Kamala Harris has actually said,
oh, well, you know Biden is
so busy doing other things,
he's not even gonna get
around to legalizing
or descheduling marijuana
at the federal level,
which is also something
that was kind of promised.
So it's like, yeah, he's gonna
be spending tons of money,
I mean, we are
busting the budget
in a way that is unimaginable
,we can't pay for it,
bills come due.
Every dollar the government
spends is one more,
like it's a deeper
finger in your pocket
that is squeezing you in places
you shouldn't be squeezed.
It all comes back to bite us.
And Joe Biden is out of
control in that sense.
- So do you think though the
inherent problem with this,
when you talk about 11
trillion in spending
or 2.2 in COVID relief.
- Right.
- Or any of this,
that the numbers.
- Yeah.
- Are so bananas,
they're so out of control
and it makes sense to nobody.
- Yeah.
- We also know that
the budgets come in
and these papers that look
like this and nobody reads them
and all that stuff,
but that it simply is
just not sexy enough.
Like you could sit here
and explain perfectly.
- Oh, yeah.
- Why we can't keep doing this
and that eventually we're
gonna have to go to war
because we're in a mafia game,
basically wearing.
- Right.
- If you can't pay, which
we obviously can't pay,
well, you then,
you better have a bigger
gun than the other guy,
and China might call
in the debt one day.
But it just isn't sexy enough.
- I think that
that's a real issue.
And again, I'm kind of like
in the persuasion game.
Like I know what I believe,
so I don't feel a need
to express myself with,
like and say, I am
the true Scotsman,
I am the true libertarian
and don't disagree with me
otherwise you're not real
or anything like that.
What I'm trying to
do is persuade people
to have a different
view of the world,
one in which individual,
and individual freedom
and voluntary association is
at the center of everything
rather than kind of top-down
coercive controls of business,
of culture, of life.
And, yeah, that's
a real question,
and I think one of the things
that I'm trying to
talk about now more
in all of this spending
is that it's like,
when you're getting all
of your money from one guy
or from one source
and it's in the the
Capitol district,
I mean, we're in the
hunger games here
where everything is
being funneled in from
the provinces to the Capitol,
and then they spit
some of it back at you,
that comes with a huge
amount of strings attached
and it gets complicated, and
it's just freaking annoying.
Right, and, especially coming
on the heels of the pandemic,
in California, in New York,
the two states where I've
spent most of the lockdown,
you have two mad men
who were being hailed as
the great saviors of humanity
by the media, by people,
by politicians
and their handlers
and all of that kind of stuff.
A Gavin Newsome and Andrew
Cuomo had been revealed
to be terrible at what they do
and one of them is a
truly awful human being,
which was hiding in plain sight.
- Wait, which one, which one?
- Well, you know what,
I'll let you our listeners.
(chuckles)
decide.
- I think I know what
you're talking about
but I'm honestly not sure.
- Yeah, we don't have to choose,
they can both be
awful human beings
as well as awful leaders.
- Yeah.
- But what we're witnessing
now is a historic moment
that I think builds
on two decades
of the government at all
levels trying to get bigger,
certainly the federal government
where it's spending more money,
it's regulating more things,
where we go from a place where,
we started the 21st
century not having to
not having to take
our clothes off
when we go to the airport,
and now we're not
only doing that,
we're talking about
seriously discussing
having to show medical papers
in order to get on
a freaking airplane.
- Yeah.
- You know, this
is serious stuff,
and this is the
ground upon which
I think we need to
persuade people to say,
you might want
that $1,400 check,
$3,600 to have a kid.
And by the way,
I just wanna say,
it is so immoral to have the
government trying to dictate
how many times you fuck,
or how many kids you have
by offering you
more and more money.
And it's also unfair to
people who don't want kids
- Hmm-mm.
- You know.
But having said any of that,
like what we need to
persuade people about
or what I'm trying to do is like
the more money you
get from a place,
the more they own you
on some level.
- Yeah.
- And what I want is,
I'm not an anarchist,
I don't think there
should be no government,
I think there should be a
strictly limited government
and a lot of what it should do
apart from like
general defense is,
it should be helping
people who are poor
or for whatever reason, don't
have the resources to fully
kind of engage or
participate in society.
Give poor people a lot of
money to go to education
to figure out how to live their
lives and things like that.
But the middle-class and upper
middle-class enrich people,
we can pay our own way,
but, we now have a government
that is promising to be
all things to all people
and that paycheck,
that paycheck from the
government doesn't come free.
So.
- So, with all that being said
and you mentioned you
voted for Joe Jorgensen
and I had her on the show
and we had.
- Hmm.
- A great conversation
for an hour,
and I don't know.
- Yeah.
- If you happen
to see the clip
but she made a terrible
mistake at the end
because she.
- I,
yes.
(chuckles)
- She flat out asked me if
I was gonna vote for her.
And my feeling was I had to
make an honest calculation,
that this was gonna be.
- Yeah.
- A close election,
and that everything that
you just said about spending
and a series of other things,
I thought Biden was gonna
usher in and wokeness.
- Right.
- And all of the stuff.
So my calculation was Trump
is the last guy
guarding the door,
so, I had to tell her that
and the clip went viral
and all that stuff.
- Yes.
- But, do you think that
was a fair estimation
when you hear sort of
libertarian minded.
- yeah.
- Or classical liberal types.
- Make that move?
Did that seem sane to you
even though you
didn't make the move?
- Yeah, you know what,
I would never hold a
vote against a person,
and or let me put it this way,
like in an American context,
I don't understand,
I vote for the person
who I think represents me
and it's kind of like,
I'm choosing a Pokemon
(chuckles)
to represent me
in a Pokemon battle or
something like that.
And I just wanna point out
there, at The Daily Mail,
there is an incredible photo
of Hunter Biden
(chuckles)
in a scene with two women.
- I saw this.
- Sitting on his body
and in the pack is
a stuffed Squirtle,
who is like a very
basic Pokemon,
and I'm like, wow, that is like,
Squirtle wants to go
back into his pokey ball.
- Yeah.
- But,
having said all of that,
I mean, I understand why
people have a libertarian
or classical liberal,
a conservative,
or even a liberal
bent, voted for Trump
because I do think
Biden is bad news.
You know what's
fascinating too is
as we're doing more and
more analysis of the vote
that Trump weirdly picked
up more ethnic votes.
- Hmm-mm.
- He picked up more
black votes, he picked
up more Hispanic votes,
he picked up a lot
of votes from women
as well as men of color
and things like that,
so like, there's something
interesting going on
that we're not
really talking about
because everybody's either,
Trump and the election
was stolen or Biden,
and like, let's not look
in the rear view mirror
because where we're going,
we're just spending
money all the time.
We can't talk about
anything else.
So I think it was a
rational position,
for me, I'm coming at it
from a different angle,
and what I'm more interested
about is the outcome,
the kind of like
a whole gestalt.
- Hmm.
- And I
was actually hoping to be
honest that Trump would win
and that he would be hemmed
in by a democratic Congress
or a mixed Congress
and that we would start getting
towards some of the stuff
that he had said as a president,
or as a candidate in 2016
that would have reduced the
size, scope and
spending of government,
which I don't think
he really did.
So, yeah.
- Well, without getting
too lost on Trump,
I mean.
- Yeah.
- My feeling also
with him was that
he was almost as libertarian
as we were ever gonna get,
or at least anytime soon.
- Yeah.
- Meaning,
even though spending
exploded for sure,
he did cut taxes.
- right.
- We didn't get into new Wars,
he did do some criminal
justice reform.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like there was stuff there.
- He was straight on
(indistinct) choice
which.
- Yeah.
- I think is really important.
He was so terrible
for me on immigration
which is, like immigration
and drug policy
and maybe school charts
are the three things
that I care about the most
in terms of actual politics.
So he was bad on immigration,
he was bad on free
trade, I think.
And, it's interesting of course
that Joe Biden is not
touching any of the tariffs
or any of the trade policy.
He's also talking about
changing immigration stuff,
but, you know as we
see Biden is merely,
he's the latest
president, which means
that he's the latest president
to put kids in
cages on the border
and all of that kind of stuff.
The distance between
Biden and Trump
has been exaggerated
by everybody
because everybody has
a reason to do that.
- Hmm-mm.
- But,
yeah, Trump,
one of the things though
that I think Trump supporters
have to deal with
too is that like
between November
and January 6th,
I mean he had a breakdown
and the way he acted
I think is the reason
why the Democrats
now control the Senate
or have a basic,
like a slimmest of
working majority's there.
I think he did a real disservice
ultimately to the country,
I don't care about
the Republican Party,
the Democratic Party,
but like he ushered
in a weird moment,
which ultimately through
the Senate to the Democrats,
I will go on record
there, Dave, and say,
and this goes back to that
mythical fictional conversation
where I was saying,
hey, there are ebbs
and flows of stuff.
- Yeah.
- The Democrats
lost seats in the house, even
as they maintain the majority,
they will lose control of
the house of representatives
in the 2022 election.
- Yeah.
- I think the Republicans
will also likely gain back
control of the Senate
because even though Biden is,
he is the rich kid who comes
to a party and is buying,
giving everybody a bottle of
Crystal or something like that.
People don't like him
and they know we are
living on borrowed time.
Democrats are not popular,
their agenda is not popular.
The problem is the Republicans,
what we have almost,
and every time people,
I think they didn't
vote for Trump
who got in totally fairly on
the slimmest of majorities,
what a brilliant campaign he ran
but they were voting
against Hillary,
this time they were
voting against Trump,
and I think in 2022,
they're gonna be voting against
Biden and the Democrats.
- Yeah, all right, let's.
- And that's good news
for the Republicans.
- Let's get back to
the idea of portion
and a little less in the.
- Yeah.
- The Trump machine.
- And the Biden
thing and all that.
Do you find that there's
any meaningful distinction
between classical liberal and
libertarian at this point?
- I don't know.
When I started at Reason
we were kind of like,
some people were talking about,
we need to take the
word liberal back
because in the 19th century
and really starting in,
I guess 17th century, liberal
meant that you believe that
people should have more freedom
to decide what matters
in their own life.
And it was a new kind of
position that came in England
and political philosophy
(chuckles)
after killing the King and
beheading Charles the first,
and you had this brief flowering
of liberal political philosophy,
which of course in the
immediate aftermath,
and this is worth
thinking about,
Oliver Cromwell led a
successful civil war
and revolution, kills a
King, one of the first times
that that had happened
certainly in British history
where people in
the name of like,
of enfranchisement
of everybody.
- Hmm.
- Or any people,
chop off the King and replace
them with a Commonwealth,
with a Republic, within
a couple of years,
Cromwell was placing his
son as the next leader.
You know, things went
bad pretty quickly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- By the end of the 17th
century, things were better,
but people were saying, oh,
we should reclaim liberal
because it's our word first.
And then we came up
with libertarian,
Friedrich Hayek famously said,
libertarian is a bullshit term,
it's not a good descriptor.
I don't know if
there's a difference
between classical
liberal and libertarian,
it seems to me to come down to
that a lot of people who are
more kind of conservative
in their personal lives
and personal choices,
but are libertarian, call
themselves classical liberal.
It may be also that a
number of libertarians,
and this bothers me in a way
that I get into trouble
with libertarians,
over the past quarter century,
a lot of libertarians actually
have drifted into anarchism.
- Hmm-mm.
- Which
and they toggle back and
forth between saying,
like I'm a libertarian,
because I don't believe
in any government,
which is not libertarianism,
as I understand
it, it's anarchism.
And so I'm good
with libertarian,
I don't know that
there is a strong
functional difference
between a classical liberal
and a libertarian, because
I think we both believe
in some government should
be strictly limited,
should be much smaller
than what we do
and everything government
does in my view,
and I think liberals
agree with this generally,
classical liberals,
it should be done in a
way to facilitate people
being able to
participate more fully
in society.
- Hmm-mm.
- And it's not about
punishing people
for being successful,
for being rich,
for being good looking,
for being talented,
it's more about
how do we raise up
the people who need help?
That's the function
of government
along with keeping
our border safe.
- By the way, for the record,
I actually don't think
there's a really meaningful
distinction anymore.
- Yeah.
- The only reason I even
asked the question is
because for me, as someone
that wrote a book defending
classical liberalism.
- Yeah.
- For me to keep going out
there and saying, I'm a liberal,
or for Bill Maher
even at this point
to keep saying.
- Right.
- I'm a liberal, it's
become so confusing that
I've always said
from the beginning,
I don't mind if someone calls
me a libertarian, I don't
- Good.
Yeah, and you know, and we're
going through these phases,
you recall back in the 80s,
and in 1988 George H.
W. Bush was able to
get a rise out of crowed
by calling Mike Dukakis
the L word.
- Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
- And stuff like that.
And the idea that liberal
had become polluted
and liberal has faded,
I mean, because people,
Democrats either say I'm a
Democrat, or I'm a progressive.
And I think to the
extent that Democrats,
there's a lot of centrist
people in the country,
I think 60% of people probably
or certainly 40% of people
are roughly in the middle.
And I think there's a
lot of classical liberal,
libertarian beliefs, they
believe in leaving people alone
and kind of fiscal
responsibility,
fiscal conservativism,
social liberalism, but the
left and the democratic party
to the extent it gets
captured by progressive's.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna leave
a lot more people looking
towards the center
and towards kind of
liberal, classical liberal,
libertarian positions.
- I keep saying it, I
think maybe it's nuts
but what you just
described there
of sort of the live
and let live attitude.
I think.
- Yeah.
- I think that it's probably,
I honestly believe this,
if people could really
understand the issues
clearly and not get
lost in the show,
I really believe that's probably
like 80% of the country.
That may sound nuts,
but I think it is.
I'm curious though
'cause you mentioned
the AAN cap thing,
and I'm sure.
- Yeah.
You know Michael Malice
and I love having him
on the show.
- Yes, yeah, yeah.
- I think he's a great
anarchist thinker.
- Right.
- I love intellectually
that exercise of like how
far we can do that thing
to end up in "Mad Max",
what is like the sort of
line for you where it's like,
no, no, that's too far?
- You know, it's, for me,
it's more like, I believe in
and this is popular among
kind of libertarians,
I believe in transhumanism and
life extension and longevity.
So I'm hopeful that I'm gonna
live to be like 200 years old.
You know, I doubt it, but
a guy can hope, right?
- They're working on
it, working on it.
- Even if I live to be 200,
I just don't have
the time to like
start arguing about
everything about,
(laughing)
okay, this is how we get
the government out of this
and this and this.
And like I'm in favor
of that direction,
I think in general
the government is not
good at what it does.
You know, it it's
either incompetent
or ineffective or inefficient
or it's kind of villainous,
one of the reasons you had ask,
how did I become a libertarian?
And part of it is after
I graduated college,
and before I got into the
lucrative teen mag business,
(laughing)
I was,
I wrote for a bunch of
newspapers in New Jersey,
I was a reporter
and I would always have to go
to planning board meetings.
And like, if you wanna turn
people into libertarians,
like just busload school,
bus school kids to planning
board meetings where people,
just the people in
charge just rail
against anybody who
had the temerity
to like improve their land,
or their house without
getting the right permits.
And half of the cases I saw,
like people didn't
even know like, oh,
I needed to go to
the city council
to put up a fence or like
to make my house better.
It's like, screw you,
but, in any case, I just,
I don't feel a need to have a
philosophical discussion
about everything.
I like the idea that in general
the government
should be doing less
and what it should be doing,
it should be competent at it,
it should be coming
up with good solutions
and that's why I liked stuff
like school choice where,
if you led,
most school funding is done
at the local and state level,
if you took all of
the money that a state
or a school district
spends per student
and just gave it to the parents
and said, okay, you can
use this wherever you want.
You can go to the public school
or you can find
a private school,
you can teach your kid at home.
Like to me, that's a win
because it would allow
people more freedom
and more autonomy to an end cap,
I'm the problem
because I'm not saying,
it's gotta be like rock
and roll high school,
you gotta blow up.
- Right.
- Vince Lombardi high at the end
and it's gotta be
on fire otherwise
you're not a real libertarian.
And I'm like, yeah, okay,
it's just like, I've
only got 200 years, man.
(chuckles)
I've only got 200 years.
- Yeah.
Or you could be debating
with Elizabeth Warren
who doesn't want school
choice but sends her kids
to private school.
- no, well, this is,
one of the things that
I hope the past year
and I don't, and we're
coming out of it,
like, everybody's
getting vaccinated
and the rush to vaccination,
by the way.
- Yeah, I wanted to say so.
- This is a great
libertarian win where it's like,
and this is something good
that Donald Trump did,
he said, you know what,
well, obviously the government
isn't gonna come up
with these vaccines,
so we're gonna give, what
seems like a lot of money,
several billion dollars to
companies to develop vaccines
compared to the
trillions of dollars
that we have spent
on COVID relief
that is mostly going
down the toilet somewhere
it's a real bargain,
but like that's a kind
of libertarian solution
where it's like, okay, we're
gonna incentivize people
to do something that's
for the public good.
- Hmm-mm.
- The roll-outs
have been kind of screwed up,
partly because of people like
Gavin Newsom or Andrew Cuomo.
But that's a good thing to do,
as we're coming out
of the COVID lockdown,
I hope we don't lose the
lessons, which is like,
you don't want the
government telling,
you don't want the government
controlling every
aspect of your life.
Even to the point of
saying, you know what,
you are an essential worker,
you are in an
essential business.
So, you're a clothing
store, screw you,
you're locked down for
three months or six months.
You are a pharmacy, so you
get to open for these hours,
you're a liquor store,
in New York city at
first liquor stores
were not considered essential,
that got changed
really quickly.
(chuckles)
But something like
a liquor store,
but then another type of
store as opposed to saying,
you know what, if
you're following these
safety protocols,
because we're in a
public health emergency,
anybody who's following
these general rules,
they can do whatever they want.
They can open their business,
how they want, et cetera.
- Well, the height of
hypocrisy would be that Target
and the big box stores
remained open.
- yeah.
- But if you were a small store
that sells the same
stuff as Target,
you were closed.
- Yeah.
- I mean.
- My main domicile,
I live in Manhattan
and lower Manhattan,
not far from a Kmart
and like clothing stores all
over the city were closed down
because they didn't serve
in a central function.
Kmart, because it sells some
food and it has a pharmacy
was open.
So, that's the last
remaining Kmart,
I mean, like, you talk about
(laughing)
"Mad Max Thunderdome",
it's like the last place where
you could shop for clothes
in New York city for a number
of months was freaking Kmart,
you know?
And it's like, yeah,
that's just not fair.
You know, it's just not fair
and it didn't do
anything to promote
or preserve public health.
So.
- So, where are you at with ice,
well, I think I sense where
you're at with the vaccine
but if you wanna go
on that a little bit,
but more so the
vaccine passport,
because this seems
to be the next step.
- Yeah.
- In the Liberty fight.
- Yeah, I don't like,
I was relieved to see that the,
the Biden white house has said,
and this is only a few days ago,
they said, we're not gonna be
getting involved in
a vaccine passport,
we don't see a role for the
government to be
administering them.
So I'm glad to hear that
- But what is that,
do you see that as like
kind of a wink, wink,
like, yeah, 'cause you guys
all do it all.
- Well.
- You big businesses
in airlines and.
- That's an interesting question
and I'll get to that in a second
because.
- Yeah.
- They did also say
we will issue guidelines.
We're not gonna enforce anything
but we're gonna
issue guidelines,
and then you start
saying like, okay,
do these guidelines
essentially become rules.
- Hmm-mm.
- And this is for me a
genuinely interesting question,
you have a couple of people
like Ron DeSantis in Florida
and Greg Abbott in Texas
kind of saying either,
preemptively
passing laws saying,
that no business
can say you need to be
vaccinated to come in here.
I have to say one of the,
again, coming out of COVID,
like so much stuff has gone
kind of gone weird where,
before COVID, you would have
businesses keeping people out
and then, and conservatives
would be cheering them.
Like, don't force cake bakers
to bake gay wedding cakes.
Right.
And conservatives are like, yes,
and now they're kind
of cheering on like
government saying to businesses,
no, you can't run your
business the way you want,
because it's perceived as in
the conservatives interests.
- Hmm-mm.
- To block passports.
I think this will shape,
well, I hope it will shake out
where some businesses
will want to say,
no shot, no shirt, no service.
And I think broadly speaking,
they should be
allowed to do that.
I think other stores
that wanna say, hey,
you don't need a shot.
You don't need to be, a shot,
you don't need shirts and
you don't need the shoes.
You know, whatever,
I think it's a better
world when we allow
everybody to set their own rules
and then live with the
consequences of that.
- Yeah.
So, but.
So the passport issue though.
- Yeah.
- I do,
again, I don't like
the idea of the,
I don't like the idea
of the government
setting these
really strict terms
for like you walking
around in public.
What does it mean that we'll
have like a passport vaccine?
Is it the type of
thing where police
will be able to kind of
stop you on the street
and say like, hey, if you've
been vaccinated or not
and even if,
is it gonna become kind
of like the stop and frisk
for coronavirus.
- Hmm-mm.
- Or something like that.
If it becomes
something like that,
I think everyone
will be against it.
I don't know,
and then you have these weird
intermediary things like,
well, what about airlines?
Because some airlines
and some foreign airlines are
already starting to develop,
like you've got to show
that you've been vaccinated
before you can
get on the flight.
for a domestic flight,
I don't think so.
The other thing is that a
lot of this stuff is all,
it's a way of smuggling in
control of people's lives.
- Yeah.
- In the name of public safety
and public health.
- Yeah.
- And that we need
to stand up for.
This is something
that Michelle Fuko,
the left-wing French social
theorist, Thomas Saws,
a hardcore libertarian
critic of medicalization
of all parts of American
society, they would agree.
Appeals to public
health oftentimes
don't have anything to
do with public health,
it's about controlling
people's behavior
and making them live
the way you want to.
- So as you're
watching this happen
and the states do
their own thing,
is it giving you some sense
of satisfaction in a way,
because it's like,
oh, this is how the system
was supposed to work.
As long as the feds.
- Yeah, the referrals.
- Don't do what they're
saying they're not gonna do,
that letting Florida.
- Yeah.
- Make its choices,
and guys like us that
are from New York.
- Yes.
- And New Jersey
and live in
California, it's like,
you got to live with
your choices man.
- Yeah, no,
and to the extent that you
have more options to sort,
so, I'm a big believer,
there's a guy named
Albert Hirschman,
a political scientist.
- Hmm-mm.
- In the early 70s,
wrote a book called
"Exit Voice and Loyalty".
And he said, there were
basically three ways to register
descent from the status quo.
And one is loyalty, which
where you just give up
and you become a company man
and you do what you're told
and learn to love it.
That is not very
appealing to most people,
there's a voice where you work
within the system for reform
and you scream bloody murder
when you're about something
and that's whether
you're a Facebook user
or a resident of Arkansas
or Alaska or Alabama
and then there's exit
where you pull up stakes
and you go out on the
frontier or you leave
and you go someplace
more to your liking or,
kind of what you have
done with your show,
and you exited the young
Turks, you went to new places,
and when YouTube
gets too hot for you
you form a partnership with
the Blaze, you create locals,
all of that kind of stuff.
You do exit.
- Hmm-mm.
- Where you go to a place
that's more hospitable
or you create your own
kind of moon colony,
which is kind of great.
And so that's the dynamic
that should be at work
here as much as possible.
I do find it, it's just that the
hypocrisy or the
bad faith arguments
I think in a lot of
people where Ron DeSantis,
he was the number
one grandma killer
because he was letting people do
their own things.
- He killed
a lot of grandma's.
- Relatively people.
- That's what they
wanted us to believe.
- Yeah, and then,
but hurts to see
him now being like,
okay, you're a
business in Florida,
you can't decide how
to run your business
'cause I'm telling you,
you cannot block somebody.
Like, yes, I'm with you if you
don't wanna bake a
cake for somebody
because you don't
like how they fuck,
(chuckles)
but like,
God dammit, I'm
gonna put you in jail
if you insist on a
COVID vaccination
like.
- Do you see that as.
- I wish they were
just more systematic.
- Yeah, so I'm with you on that,
but do you, to me I can grant
him a little extra leash there
because to me it's like.
- Yeah.
- An overcorrection
because they've all gone
so insane.
- Yeah.
- So then he's saying
something that it's like
a little over the top.
- Yeah.
- But it's sort of,
it's directionally right
and I can kind of get over it.
- I think this is
one of the limits of,
sometimes when I think about,
okay, what are
libertarian ideas?
How do they affect society?
And it's that we're never gonna
live in an end cap society,
a narco capitalist society,
we're not gonna live in
a libertarian society.
But what we do is we kind of,
we add spice
or we give a direction.
- Yeah.
- That people slowly
kind of ooze over to.
And that's okay, but I, we're
bad at being tribalistic.
And it is like so,
I'm with people,
I'm with politicians,
right up until the moment that
they contravene a principle.
And this is why
people like Ted Cruz
is a good example in
the US Senate where
he came into office
as a tea party darling
and he had a good rhetoric
from generally speaking,
limited government
libertarian-ish perspective
but he just is constantly
arguing in bad faith
and flip-flopping,
because at every moment.
like if you're part of a
tribe, if you're a Republican,
it means
at a certain point.
- Hmm.
- Your principles stop
and party affiliation
takes over.
And like, I can really go there
and I think it might mean
this is why certainly
the libertarian party,
but I think more broadly
libertarians will,
we are important and we're
vital to a flourishing America
but, we're never gonna
have a 60% plural
or majority at anything.
- Right, and by the way,
that's why I like
talking about ideas
way more than politics.
- Yeah.
- Because politics just
kind of make you crazy
in case people don't like that.
- And ideas, again, well,
you know what worries me
and I know this is a
concern of yours is,
so let's say, a
Breitbart would say
that politics is
downstream from culture,
I talk about politics
as a lagging indicator.
We've had when it comes to
things like free speech,
we've had a supreme court that
for the past 25 or 30 years,
actually more like 50 years
has been really
great on free speech.
And every time, including
going back to the mid 90s
when the Clinton administration
and Republicans in Congress
wanted to regulate the internet
like a broadcast network
under the Communications
Decency Act,
the Supreme Court in a nearly,
it was like a seven to
two decision said, no,
this is an illegal abridgment
of the first amendment
of people's freedom
to speak, et cetera.
We have a good Supreme Court,
we have a culture of free speech
which has degraded so much
over the past 25 years.
The Supreme Court,
there's a joke that
the Supreme Court
reads the newspapers, like,
but we've been lucky to
have the Supreme Court
knock down a lot of
restrictions on speech,
now we're living in
a real battle ground
where people are
saying, you know what,
certain speech is offensive,
his speeches is threatening,
his speech makes me feel
unsafe, we got to get rid of it.
And they're turning the screws
on all of the places
where we can speak,
and how much longer, like
Clarence Thomas recently
in a dissent, in a
recent case was saying,
you know what, like maybe we
should be regulating Facebook
and other social media
as a common carrier,
it's like, as ABC and NBC news,
as where they can't
moderate any content.
And I'm like, holy cow,
this could be the beginning
of a really bad period for the,
not just the law of free speech,
but the culture of free speech.
- Okay, so that's exactly,
you got me to exactly
where I wanted to
spend our last.
- Yeah.
- Couple of minutes, which of
course is the big tech thing,
which for, I think.
- Yeah.
- For many libertarians has
pushed their libertarian beliefs
to the end of the line.
It's sort of a rubber
meet road moment.
- Yeah.
- So, I'm with you on that,
the Clarence Thomas thing
is really interesting
because I understand
the inclination.
- Right.
- And then on the other hand,
it's like, well, wait a minute,
then if you start
regulating them,
don't you just kind of
keep them around forever
much like ABC.
- Of course.
- And CBS and NBC and.
- That's right.
- So.
- Yeah.
- So where are you on
big tech at this point?
Because the main
line that I hear
every time you put out a
libertarian idea on big tech,
okay, build your own internet
and then they're.
- Yeah.
- Gonna blow up your servers.
So help me out.
- All right, and, I'm
working on a piece
that'll come out down
the road a little bit,
but have like, Parlor did
exactly what they were told now,
if you don't like it, and
this is where liberals
and progressives who were
telling the cake baker,
you gotta bake the damn cake.
And then they're saying
too, so they're saying,
no, you can't leave that,
you are forced to do this.
- Yeah.
- Then
when it's a conservative
saying, I want this,
then they're like, well,
build your own internet.
You know, and Parlor
did all of that
and at every step, they
were being cocked blocked
by anybody who could, whether
it was Amazon Web Services,
payment programs, app stores
and yet they persisted and
they're still out there.
And this, I think this will
be unsatisfying to you,
I think we are in a place where,
we need to say if you believe
in private property rights
and ownership and
things like that,
that Facebook does have a right
to run it service the
way that wants to.
And this is going back to
the Hirschmann stuff of
exit voice and loyalty.
I'm not being loyal, I'm
not loyal to Facebook,
I'm not loyal to almost
anything other than principals,
so like, I'm not gonna go
along with whatever
Facebook wants,
I'm gonna scream bloody murder
on Facebook, on YouTube,
in the internet, at Twitter
which did an abominable
thing last fall
when they blocked the
New York post story
about Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden before the election.
It's like insane, I
was like apoplectic,
and they did kind of
walk it back a little bit
but it's a constant fight
because every time
you turn your back,
they're trying to turn down
a little bit more
sphere of free speech.
- Well, now we're seeing
Hunter Biden, bang this girl
with Charmander
sitting next to him,
or who was it?
- Yes.
- Not Charmander, Squirtle?
- It was Squirtle.
I would have thought
it was, he would have,
I thought Charmander.
- Yeah.
But you would think
he'd be a Charmander
guy, but he's a Squirtle,
which is just too
much to think of that.
- It's too on the money, yeah.
- Yeah, but,
(chuckles)
but, you have to
scream bloody murder
and then you also have to be
constantly building
alternatives.
And, one of the things
that I like is that,
just as Twitter is getting worse
in terms of it's arbitrary,
it's ideological,
it's politically correct.
You know, suddenly clubhouse
appears.
- Hmm-mm.
- As a place where you can
have more free and open
and different types
of discussions.
Then you see people starting
to move in there saying like,
you know what, the
problem with clubhouses,
nobody's recording
and reporting on everything
everybody's saying all the time.
- It's unfettered,
that's what it said.
in the New York Time.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, unfettered.
Like my grandparents
all left Ireland
and Italy to get out of fetters,
it's like,
(laughing)
nobody wants fetters,
for Christ's sake.
But and so clubhouse,
you can already see
the beginning of
the end of clubhouse
but there'll be something
there after that.
And it's a push pole
where it's not a utopian,
you're like super idealistic
or inspirational outcome,
but I think between voice and
exit and a constant pushing,
that's where freedom
is gonna resolve
and I'm a big fan of a
concept that was popular
in the 90s called
"Temporary Autonomous Zones"
and these were places where,
outside of the church,
outside of the government,
outside of school, you would
find these little places
where for a little while
you could do or say
or be whatever you wanted to be,
and burning man was like.
- Hmm-mm.
- A big example of that,
especially before burning man,
it's not that it's corporate,
but, it becomes
its own institution
and it's more fettered.
- Yeah.
- But now there are
a million other face,
burning man's and whatnot.
And I think this has to be like,
what we have to
strive for is to say,
you know what, in my life
and in everything I do,
I'm gonna be tolerant,
I'm gonna be pluralistic,
I'm going to engage people
rather than try
to shut them down
and cancel them and
screw them over.
And not only make sure that
they're not doing well,
but that anybody who
associates with them
gets put in the Gulag
figurative as may be.
We have to model that
and then we have to constantly
be building the escape hatch,
building the escape
pod and having the
figurative equivalent
of a Swiss bank account
where we can go and
have the conversations,
the lives that we want.
And, what's great
about that is that,
for all of this, ABC, NBC, CBS,
they still exist and they
still drop big numbers
but everybody's kind of drawn to
the frontier where things
are a little bit newer,
things are a little
bit more free,
bit more current.
And, that's the dynamic
that I think people
need to understand
and we need to make sure that,
I think that in a lot of ways,
that for me is what
American exceptionalism is,
is this balance between
being rooted in a community
and caring about people
and then also being ready to
light out for the territory
when this thing here
that we grow up in,
whether it's New Jersey
or New York or wherever.
It gets a little
bit too stuffed up,
it gets a little
bit too repressive,
we're gonna light out
for someplace else.
- Nick, you just gave me like
a three minute sort of Atlas
shrugged ending
sales job for Locals
because that's exactly what
I'm trying to do with Locals
we're building escape
hatch while I'm yelling
and, yeah.
- Yeah, I know.
And, it's funny
because I know a bunch of
people who are using it
and they all say the same thing
and where you guys at
Locals are doing it right
and I think this is
also starting to happen
in social media where
it's decentralized
so that it is.
- Yeah.
- Like there is
no one choke point
because this is also true,
when it comes to everything
that depends on a credit
card payment or something,
there's a choke point,
everything where
there's a central server
there's a choke point or
one person ultimately,
there's the button,
the on-off switch.
And they can flip it
one way or the other,
the future is much more
dispersed and decentralized
and we need to be
promoting that,
not simply as like,
okay, this'll do,
but like that's what we want.
And it's always better,
this may seem far field,
but like intersectionality
which has become a buzzword
in identity politics,
the way I see it, or
the way I interpreted
it's that all of us are made
up of like partial identities
and interests and
things like that,
and no one of them
defines our us fully,
but overlapping they
kind of give us a sense
but they also make
us more resilient.
They make us less
fragile because,
we have a lot of different
parts of our lives going on.
And, it's a kind of
way of decentralizing,
dispersing who we are.
It's like, horcruxes
it's like a horcrux
in Harry Potter where.
- Yeah.
- You wanna have parts of
your soul all over the place
so that you can't
get wiped out in one,
because of one bad
action or one big mistake
or one big attack,
that's what our
society has to be like.
And in a lot of ways, I think
we're groping towards that
and that's actually, if I may,
that's what drives me nuts
about political correctness
or tribal politics
whether it's
right-wing or left-wing
where people wanna take
all of the complexities
of all we do and all who we are.
- Hmm-mm.
- And say, no, you know what?
You are this one thing, whether
it's you're this religion,
you're this gender,
you're this orientation,
you're this profession
like no way, man.
You know, what was great
about the 20th century
which was a miserable century,
like I said my father
fought in World War II.
- Hmm-mm.
- There were
mass exterminations, the
Russian Gulag, all of that.
It ended in this furious
kind of firework show
of mass personalization,
mass individualization.
and then that all kind
of came crashing down.
And like, we've got to
get out of the rubble
of the global war on terror,
we've got to get out
of the garrison state
of government getting so big,
I mean, Biden is talking,
we have the rescue plan,
which was 1.9 trillion,
we've got $2.2 trillion
in infrastructure
which people are saying,
childcare is infrastructure,
toothpaste is infrastructure.
- Yes.
- And then he's got like another
200 something
trillion dollar plan.
- Yeah.
- Just down the road.
Like, we gotta leave that behind
and start getting down
to living our lives
rather than waiting for
checks that we can afford
- Nick, you gave me two
Atlas shrug endings there..
Very.
- I guess so.
- Yeah.
- yeah, maybe,
and I will admit that I've
never read "Atlas Shrugged",
I've never finished it.
I've watched the
movies, which I enjoyed
(laughing)
and I know the basic plot,
and I kind of liked
the idea of Gulch-Gulch
but I also worry
that Gulch-Gulch
would be like the worst
homeowners association.
- Well, that's what.
- You know, you can.
Everybody's armed, right,
so it's like, okay.
I mean, I guess I believe
like Robert Heinlein and
William Burroughs said
that an armed society
is a pleasant society
but I don't know if I
would wanna live in Gulch,
I think I would wanna have
a friend who has a condo
or a timeshare there.
- Listen, I cannot
believe we did not do this
in all these years, so
I really enjoyed this.
And let's just say, let's
just say I was hypothetic,
ooh, I've said too much,
let's just say someone
was hypothetically
gonna have some
sort of get together
with a bunch of political
dissidents and sit around a fire
and smoke some weed in
the next couple of days.
Would that be something
that would hypothetically
interest someone like you?
- You know, that is
hypothetically a yes.
It's always fascinating.
And the only thing
better than potential is,
is the potential energy
is real energy, right, so.
- Nick, I will hypothetically
see you on Friday night
and we'll link to all
your stuff down below
and it was good seeing you, man.
Thank you so much Dave.
(tranquil ambient music)
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch
full interviews on
a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.